Film Courage: Why are there so many screenwriters
opposed to structure?
Are they hurting or helping themselves with
this viewpoint?
Eric Edson: There are a lot of people (always
will be) some of them Sir Tom Stoppard himself
(no less a writer than Tom) is really opposed
to education, this education that is now offered
in graduate schools, screenwriting and all
that.
But he can afford to be.
You know, if you’re born a genius…okay,
go for it!
You can say anything you want, you can do
anything, and you write brilliantly and for
them, it’s natural.
But for most of us poor unfortunates below
the peak of Olympus.
Yeah, we have to work a little harder at it.
I think…I think it is a misconception of
what there is to be learned.
Many, many people have always done it a certain
way and they sit and suffer and think there
is a muse that comes down.
Some people may be very intuitive about this
story stuff and for them…yeah…fine it
can work.
But what I find is for the vast majority of
people who want to be writers (screenplays
or novels), that’s not the case.
There are tools, tools, tools.
Tools one needs to master.
Before you are going to play inspirational
and fantastical orchestral music for instance.
You’re going to compose.
Don’t you need to know how to play the piano?
Well, yeah…that helps.
Don’t you need to know about music and the
theories of music and composition.
It would help.
You’d save yourself a lot of time and trouble
if you’d do that.
And I believe very much that it’s the same
with screenwriting.
There is so much to learn.
There really is.
And the folks that tend to think that way
and defend it.
Okay, that’s the way they’ve always worked.
I get that.
That’s the way you want to work.
Great.
Do it.
But I believe they are bringing their own
lives far more emotional suffering than there
needs to be.
It’s not the muse, folks.
There is not muse.
It’s up to you to come up with a decent
idea so you can then pull out the correct
tools to start shaping into something that
will work and will bring emotional sustenance
and release for an audience.
Film Courage: I think you had a blog post
where I just skimmed the beginning of it where
you wrote you know…We wake up, the birds
are chirping and we’re inspired.
And we are going to write.
And then we get into page 47 and we’ve hit
a roadblock.
So is this what we’re talking about here,
sort of how to find a way out of that road
block.
Because if we’re at page 47, which is this
point of the story.
Are we at the mid-point by the way?
Eric Edson: Ahhhh…48ish.
47ish.
That’s about the mid-point.
Yes.
I have always said no plan.
No detailed plan, no Oscar.
It’s just not going to happen.
If you’re going to build a house (and especially
an intricate one, as one as intricate as a
screenplay for a really good movie, you have
to have architectural renderings that take
it down to the tiniest dimensions and details
and piece of equipment that is going to be
used.
You have to be organized about it.
Disorganized people (as a rule) don’t do
all that well as writers, screenwriters.
Again, this is not everybody!
There are in fact geniuses (don’t you just
hate them?) out there who can do this stuff
just instinctively without even thinking about
it.
But there is a handful of them living on planet
earth at any given time.
And of course maybe they can’t see it from
our perspective that ‘Gee maybe you’d
have to work at it?’
But, yes.
There is a lot of work and a lot to be known.
And isn’t it better if you lay the pieces
out…you have a puzzle board before you and
you have all the dark pieces here and the
light pieces here and you begin to search
and see and fit together something that is
going to be a full picture by the time you’re
through.
That is a systematic way of doing something
that is very difficult to do.
I would argue tools, tools, quantifying change,
understanding the 14 character categories.
Knowing that there are 10 modes of plot coming
out of how many heroes and what the heroes
relationship is other characters.
There’s only 10 of those.
Once you have an idea, pick your 10.
That’s going to save you a lot of time and
a lot of agony.
And I would also throw this out.
I would challenge…listen I am open as anybody
to learn here.
I am a life-long learner myself.
If someone thinks I am wrong here or has an
instance and if they can prove that I am wrong,
I’d be very interested to hear it.
I really would If you think you’ve found
a 15th category (for instance)…if you’ve
taken a look at the 14 and understand what
is contained in the 14.
If you can come up with a brand new character
category, I would love to be one of the first
to hear about it (really).
I offer that to the students all of the time.
Usually when I hear back, when they bring
things up, rather enthusiastically (bless
their hearts), it’s usually from a misunderstanding
of the 14 or it’s a misunderstanding of
what I’m saying relative to hero goal sequences
and things like that.
But it’s okay.
I’m happy about hearing of ways in which
I might be incorrect with this stuff.
There is room for growth.